[Music]
saturday night live
kicked off season 46 with lots of star
power
mr vice president just one second chris
[Music]
okay yup that's jim carrey making his
snl debut as democratic candidate joe
biden
while alec baldwin once again took on
the role of president donald trump
each candidate will have two minutes
uninterrupted boring
mr president i haven't even introduced
the candidates yet
tell that to my adderall chris now let's
get this show on the road and off the
rails
and off the rails it went as the 2020
presidential debate skit went on
carries biden struggled to control his
anger by talking to himself
i said two words you son of a no
don't do it joe breathing into a bag
okay and eventually
losing his thought look here's the deal
no lost it come back to me as baldwin's
trump cuts him off at
every turn which eventually forces biden
to tell the president to
shut up just like in the real debate
look
here's the deal can i respond to that
chris will you just shut up man
thankfully maya rudolph's kamala harris
comes on stage as the voice of reason
oh i got this
let mama go to work after forcing trump
to apologize
mamala gave musical guests megan the
stallion and cardi b's song wap
a whole new meaning america needs a whop
woman as president
for the opening monologue host chris
rock took the studio 8-h
stage to explain how the show managed to
have an audience while still
keeping safe everybody in this audience
has been
checked and all week i've had things
going up my nose
every day i come in here i haven't had
so much stuff up my nose since i
shared a dressing room with chris farley
the comedian went on to address
president trump's coven 19 diagnosis
president trump's in the hospital from
covet
and i just want to say my heart goes out
to covet
also taking aim at trump weekend update
anchors colin jost and michael che
it's been very weird to see all these
people who clearly hate trump come out
and say we wish him well
i think a lot of them are just guilty
that their first wish came true
by the way is is anyone surprised by
this i honestly thought trump was trying
to get corona fire
look i don't want the president to die
obviously you know actually i wish him a
very lengthy recovery
kate mckinnon honored the woman she
played so brilliantly many times the
notorious
rbg
[Music]
the moment was brief but powerful and
came at the end of the night's weekend
update
the segment where mckinnon most
frequently portrayed the beloved supreme
court justice
and megan the stallion made her snl
debut
absolutely slaying it
[Music]
the rapper also used the platform to
deliver
a powerful message we need to protect
our black women
and love our black women because at the
end of the day
we need our black women nagin also
called out kentucky attorney general
daniel cameron over his handling of the
brianna taylor case
daniel cameron is no different than the
sellout negroes
that sold our people into slavery
you